[Music]
[Music]
in the year 1822
in the little town of arbor france was
born a son to the village tanner
whose shop was right beside the river
the boy was named louis
louis pasteur he was a plotting careful
boy
with no particularly great talents but
he did have an indomitable will
a fiery temper and the great capacity
for work
he became a chemist
it was louis pasteur who opened up which
menace its very
existence he made us conscious for the
first time
of this vast and vital microscopic life
by his daring and original experiments
he the chemist made modern medical
science possible
by sweeping away the ancient theories of
disease
by such things as spirits dispositions
and devils they were devils
but of a very different kind concrete
living destructive microbes
he definitely and completely smashed the
belief
that microbes came into existence by
spontaneous generation
his opponents shouted and ranted against
him
but he performed his experiments and
silenced the unbelievers
with indisputable facts microbes
are born from other microbes they do not
come to life automatically and
spontaneously
from nowhere this
did pastor prove
the academy of medicine in paris was the
citadel of the medical profession in
france
among its members were the most
illustrious physicians and scientists
as well as the most stubborn
in the general auditorium of this famous
academy
it was the custom for the members to
present their theories and discoveries
to be discussed by the other colleagues
many times had pasteur faced the men of
this academy
and many times had the meetings turned
into stormy arguments
between pasteur the chemist and those
prejudiced and narrow-minded enough
to regard him as a quack
how often had he presented his
discoveries
only to shock the elders from their
complacency
how often had he roused them from their
small and unprogressive worlds
to vistas of that new universe of deadly
as well as beneficial microbes
at times to be applauded and at times to
be laughed at
despised and accused as a faker
before this assembly he had presented
his experiments in fermentations
thus saving the wine industry for france
and gave to the world
the process now known as pasteurization
a simple method of heating from this
platform had he explained
how he had saved the silk industry by
tracking down
the microbe and in this auditorium
had he given science his most famous
discovery
immunization by a process of building up
a resistance against a specific germ
first by a weak and then by increasingly
stronger injections of that very same
germ
he had discovered that he could create
immunity
the first step in curing many terrible
diseases
he had discovered the nature of vaccines
he would make his patient just a little
sick with a very weak
germ and permit him to recover then he
could withstand the most
deadly microbes of the same species
he had tamed microbes to fight other
microbes
the same one that killed was the one
that guarded against
death tirelessly he and his faithful
assistants
searched experimented and searched again
it needed the patience ability and
imagination
of a true scientist and genius and
pasteur was all of that
but these men only blustered their
objections
pasteur's weapons were his laboratory
and scientific truth
these stubborn enemies of his are now
long since forgotten
while louis pasteur will never be
when pasteur was nine years old he had
seen a peasant suffering from an attack
by a mad dog
he heard the groans of pain as the man
was tortured by the horrible disease
hydrophobia this memory no doubt
prompted pastor to find the cause of
that scourge of mankind
he drove his assistance almost to
desperation
but finally he knew he had succeeded
but the great proof still remained to be
shown
could pastor save human lives
dared he try his cure on the human body
he faced a terrible choice and in a
letter to a friend
he wrote he would inoculate himself with
a frightful germ
and then try to cure himself
but fate mercifully relieved him of such
a decision
a boy joseph meister was brought to him
he had come from a nearby village
the old grandfather told pastor how
little joseph had gone out to the fields
to play
only two days ago
he had often done so and never before
had there been any danger
happily scampering down a familiar
country road
which had never held any fears for him
he had suddenly met the strange and
raving mad dog
the beast ravaged by the terrible rabies
had attacked the boy and mangled him
with 14
wounds save my boy pleaded the old man
it is still not too late tenderly
pastor carried the boy to a bed was this
his opportunity to try his new vaccine
why hesitate and yet he was
experimenting with a human life
such a young life too should he or
should he not
the boy would surely die from the dread
disease
he might live if pasteur would try his
vaccine
it had worked on his animals he had
proved that beyond a doubt
there was no other protection against
this disease that strangled its victims
only pastor could save him maybe
his faithful assistant the physician who
could administer the cure did not
hesitate
there was no choice it was sure death
or possible life the vaccine was
prepared
for the final test
that night july 6 1885
the first inoculation against rabies was
made
then past anxious hours anxious days
each day joseph meister received an
increasingly stronger dose
of the life-saving vaccine building up
an immunity against the time
when the deadly germ should strike its
fatal blow
of what did pastor think as he paced the
room
perhaps he remembered his many failures
perhaps he remembered how his anthrax
cure for cattle
at first proved to be a huge success and
then had failed
that was four years before in 1881
when he had tried his first vaccine for
anthrax
would he fail now how often had he
fumbled his way
how often had he made mistakes he
couldn't be wrong now
he had been stubborn about hydrophobia
and had not stopped until he had been
absolutely sure
well as sure as he could be
on the 14th day the unseen enemy
was conquered
all the world then paid tribute to this
man of science
this benefactor of mankind institutes
were established in his name
streets were called after him statues
were built
louis pasteur's name became known to the
four corners of the earth he was the
first man to make the world fear and
respect
the almost invisible microbe more
dangerous than
canon were these tiny creatures and yet
more beneficial too than the greatest of
healers
pastors life had been a busy one he had
worked hard with his hand
and his brain and nature began to take
its toll
his hair turned white and age sat
heavily upon his shoulders
there was still much work to be done but
his family and his friends persuaded
him to rest let others take off the
tremendous tasks before mankind
where he had left off and so
he heeded their words and went to live
in his home in the country
there to think and even to plan greater
experiments against the invisible
enemies
those hordes of vicious microbes
even when he himself was inactive
physically
he was in constant touch with the work
in progress at the institute
named in his honor and his spirit was
tireless
then to crown a career as brilliant as
any man's in history
whether king or philosopher france rose
to pay a final tribute
to her native son a great meeting was
held in his honor
at the famous university of the sorbonne
in paris
it was in 1892 on pastor's 70th birthday
and this was a great day for france and
for louis
pasteur
men famous the world over were there to
pay him homage
men from every walk of life scientists
statesmen teachers poets
and students representatives from every
civilized nation on earth
were there to greet him and yet
among all those present there were none
so famous and so revered
as he himself he had shown mankind the
road to health
he had shown mankind the path to a
greater freedom and the more generous
life
he had opened another door of knowledge
and truth
and had shown the world a greater glory
in the protection
of the human body
leaning on the arm of the president of
the french republic
pasteur entered the great hall cheered
lustily by all present
his final words were to those young
students of the famous university
and he said this do not let yourselves
be
tainted by a deprecating and barren
skepticism
do not let yourselves be discouraged by
the sadness of certain
hours which pass over nations
live in the serene peace of laboratories
and libraries
say to yourselves first what have i done
for my instruction
and as you gradually advance what have i
done for my country
until the time comes when you may have
the immense happiness of thinking
that you have contributed in some way to
the progress and good
of humanity
[Music]
[Music]
you